[Música]
totó não usa mais o vídeo em que o
ginásio a fazer o máximo potencial para
37 lápis mas vocês quiserem projeto que
usar óculos de proteção
lá
[Música]
agora eu sei que vocês não têm em casa
então vocês podem fazer é juntar duas
público tamanho a4 que são aquelas que
nós usamos para imprimir o tamanho a3 e
depois vocês têm de escolher o tamanho
a3 utilizando uma cola cola tevê alta
daquela cola branca que é muito barata
espalhados ou usar um pincel está muito
trabalho a fazer e vou perder muito
tempo que vocês podem fazer para ser
mais fácil é usar tudo o que tenha um
dia entre 1 5 e 2 podem usar uma vara de
madeira com com 12 ou então podem ver
paula e procurar o milan tem a opção e
vocês podem ver fumaça
vocês têm os instrumentos para cortar ou
não está no youtube sem cortar nada e
depois temos dois a volta que tem 35
centímetros e um desnível de mais ou
menos
um centro agora temos que juntar os
tubos que estão lado esquerdo temos um
tubo com 10 em tempos normais e dois com
11 em tempos de ldu e para juntar tudo
isso usar uma cola 500 porque ela é
barata seca rápido lira basicamente é
mais prática de todas
isso não quer dizer que você não possa
usar escolas lá em casa só que como
moram muito tempo para ficar novamente
vai ficar muitos cantos para você só tem
imagine só ficar à espera que um minuto
que cada coisa col no morumbi entrar
para fazer estes brinquedos até agora
vamos lutar aqui dois tubos grandes à
tarde o português com 42 centros do lado
e do outro estava falaram queremos que
vocês quiserem podem usar madeira seja é
dessa maneira como quiserem bahia mas se
você quiser mandar eu gostava de fazer
mas o problema é como muitas pessoas não
têm detectar com em casa então optei por
fazer papel nos comentários
vocês gostariam que fizessem alguma arma
utilizando madeira e que a arma seria
essa a lançar foi elástico da aula bem o
que vocês querem que eu faça utilizando
madeira nos comentários a cair agora vou
colar um pedaço de dois centímetros um
lado eo cuidado dos sentimentos do outro
lado
agora uma coisa que vamos ter aqui no
tutorial é que dois pedaços pequenos
erros foram reforçados utilizando cola
ou seja depois de cortar a volta do
corta sant colante naquela zona circular
um lado e na zona situada do outro lado
isso porque porque mais para frente eu
vou colocar um ex passa por uma mãe dos
dois tubos então como é que eu fique bem
forte
agora estou preencher os tubos que
faltam até ao final seja o estudo tem
que acabar todos no mesmo fique único se
destaca para central tubo do cano que
essa é uma questão bem feito mesmo mas
outros acabam todos ali no mesmo tempo
[Música]
e com mel de vocês podem dar uma forma
de enfrentar mas não quero ser igual é
como estou fazendo aqui até que vocês
quiserem podem mandar prefiro um
espermograma ano foi o que nós temos em
que vocês fazem aqui em casa agora
utilizar demais aqui dois tubos que seu
estudo não vamos usar de fundo 30
centímetros depois mais cinco que vocês
vão viajar do rio para que isto tem que
acabar quando acaba os outros lhe à
frente até 40 e pela aquela faca por não
colar até aonde acabar e deixar no
centro
agora temos aqui um quinto dos jesuítas
competidores têm quintas não precisa
ficar todos podem escolher o tamanho que
vocês acharem melhor para vocês e podem
pôr mais paciente mais para trás desta
parte onde vocês vão agarrar a arma
então fica ao vosso critério de um lado
do outro e é curioso fica um tiro ou
seja ter uma cor diferente restar manhã
em termos de design fica muito melhor
então eu era como se podem ver
exatamente difícil para a zona de pensão
no design com estava agora que você se
inspirar em um triângulo de cada lado
que completamente franco está muito
melhor agora o jovem está muito mais que
chegar e começar a falar eu queria que
vocês darem sugestões comentários
eu estou falando de uma seleção você
deus vocês querem que eu faço aqui no
canal por basileia é muito importante e
eu gosto sempre de tentar fazer o que
vocês pedem até vocês me diziam certa
forma fazer coisas e rolar e branca
só quero muito fazer isso então vou
fazer agora vou juntar duas coisas
porque amanhã 3 mas elas são conectadas
maneira diferente seja estou juntar as
partes mais pequenas da folha a3 a outra
parte mais pequena folha a 37
no início nós juntarmos as partes
maiores da folha umas às outras a que
estamos a juntar as duas partes mais
pequenas da escolha do time e vamos lá
agora volta da rifa do tamanho de uma
folha a3
então vocês puderam ver no início esta
foi a 3 no verde foi feita com duas
folhas a4 é muito importante vocês
baterem se encontra mesmo para alinhar
tudo e fazer como a pergunta mãe passar
cola espalharam com o pincel é muito
importante vamos limpar e pensa logo
depois de terminar isto porque não vai
estragar já poder quando o número tem
caído já estraguei porque deixei com
cola e fui pra casa agora fazer aqui
vários buracos
se vocês não tiverem fora da área
estiver em broca podem fazer isso na
mesma o problema é que vai demorar mais
tempo para vocês fazerem alguma coisa
que amiga broca um pedaço de madeira por
ser mais fácil vocês julgarem vocês vão
fazer uma espécie de sábado fenda usando
a troca pois eu sou girando com a mão
para se prevenir de políticas vai entrar
mais facilmente é só vocês noticiarem
desta forma se vocês quiserem podem
colocar mais províncias vai parar mais
elásticos por não cola nesta quarta
poxa estou em busca dessa forma
desta forma vocês conseguem pôr tudo ao
mesmo nível por bater na mesa principal
diante deles ficarem não sei quantificar
qual a guerra agora disputar por cima
também a registar uma comercializar
serem é muito resistente à criação do
psd
isso porque já estou fazendo várias
vezes o áudio porque no início da manhã
a mãe tem dias que não consigo falar
nada direito
eu estou a cortar e aqui que vou
encaixar os elásticos está forçado aqui
com cola mesmo muito muito lixo e não
tem uma escola do outro lado
agora vou juntar e as partes todas eu
fiz as coisas destas
vocês quiserem podem fazer mais e fazer
o quê com tambores maior precisão tambor
maior vai ter mais elásticos também arma
vai ficar um pouco desproporcional é a
diferença entre o tambor e o corpo largo
ela ficar muito grande estar aqui com
vocês vocês fizerem conta de frente
maior e consegue manter um tambor maior
também é muito importante que ir três
coisas coisas nestas coisas como vou
chamar os políticos plantas das pílulas
de projetos fica em todas as viradas
para fora
agora vou jantar dois setores grandes
que são usados nome para espalhar será
encontrar somente agora um buraco com
tamanho é a segunda cabo um buraco para
em três centros depois votar usando uma
serra para metal instância ou seja o
tamanho desse jeito vai variar também no
tamanho do voto tambor você tem que ver
qual é a distância para vocês vocês
fizerem tudo igual à distância vai ser
igual mas vocês fizeram tambor maior tem
que entender qual é o tamanho certo para
vocês eu estou fazer um segundo
orçamento agora não faltaram tabelas
talvez
não lembrava mas fantasticamente isso é
pra dar um espaçamento e assim o tambor
não vai bater nos suporta selecção que
os dois políticos ficam de fora do lar e
vocês têm com muita cola do lado e foi
esperar que seu irmão kaká então mostrar
o que o força é este que estudar com
cola e foi assim que eu fiz aquelas 2002
entende como cair no início do vídeo que
eu vou falar que é muito importante você
coloque bastante bola de um lado e ficou
aquém do outro lado também
eu não sei no tutorial mas por seu
marido se colar colou no colo colo colo
do outro lado diz pedaço também cai
como vocês podem ver e já começa a
enviar um pouco vou fazer agora a krona
e fui muito do que no estádio na partida
frente a 0 na quarta nos tornar agora
dobrar ligeiramente para baixo e ficou
completamente diferente do que costuma
fazer não me fica sem um triângulo do
braille geralmente o livro na parte da
frente e tentar algumas leituras das
peças feitas com folhas a4 mas aquelas
normais em história e lugar com duas
cores pelo menos nas armas para trás é
boa porque vocês conseguem colocar
alguma coisa seja um fio da frente e de
trás a frente aqui a carta também com
caíu marie culturais que tenham mostrado
que o prendo fi ou seja aquela parte de
corona atrás você expõe um fio e vai até
a frente da arma e vocês conseguem pela
as costas é que vocês possam ajudar um
adulto fizerem isso até porque não é
muito fácil fazer este futuro
encaixem este pequeno mas então grande o
chamado planeta já que vocês quiserem
podem tê lo ainda mais para baixo quanto
mais para baixo vocês um terem mais
eficiente fica o sistema
no meu caso se não vai mais se vocês
quiserem poderão ter mais elásticos
então aí você tem que colocar que o
político madeira é mais afastado do
tambor quanto mais afastado melhor vai
funcionar agora estou fazer ano
[Música]
corria festas que apoiamos não têm
certeza essa justamente uma peça em que
o fio fica preso arno mais aquilo aí fui
fazer um furo usando uma broca é uma
coisa agora vou passar uma receita com
uma folha de tamanho a3 e foi entrando
deve fazer que eu fique da empresa
natureza e roldanas e manivelas um pouco
de cola para aprender a polia a manivela
ou seja o edital manivela e acrescentei
que um problema na parte de trás para
aumentar a resistência para explicar
mais tava eu estou fazendo uma coleção
de armas e eu quero fazer também a arma
centers gostariam que eu mostrasse a mãe
como é que eu vou fazer antiga ou seja
não quero fazer antigas mas voltará um
pouco tamanho
em termos de design tamanho ou fazer as
malas
agora vamos ter um filme
convém estar em o tamanho ou seja vou
enrolar o fio à volta do que eu lhes
prometo do tambor era ver o tamanho
certo e depois passou a cortar e prender
a poluir podem usar o filtro pesca opção
lá em casa e verificar se têm uma boa
resistência e não é elástico
usando uma cola qualquer proteção e por
carregarem armas
irlanda o fim desta forma seu relato de
vocês começam por da frente para trás só
quer ganhar e talvez mora em um minuto e
mais 10 minutos desta feita para reparar
essa você dá a manivela e conseguem ver
o que acontece é o único filme o filho
vai puxando o elastic para fora
enfim ter sido melhor comentário todos
uma estrela hoje estamos melhor vias
porque comentar vídeos a maré do vosso
lá que eu acho que eu estava trabalhando
que deu para construir lista não podem
porque as escutas também profundidade no
canal das coisas mais lindas com as
coisas acontecendo trazer então não
muito obrigado a depositar